hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to I hate you Mario
otherwise known as Mario dot exe this is
actually really cool because it's a
pretty faithful recreation of Super
Mario World from what I've seen like
I'll load into the first level and
you'll see what I mean cuz I just loaded
up to test it I was like oh my god it's
a direct port like it's exactly what
Super Mario World was like and that's
really cool because Super Mario World is
like cherished in my mind because one of
the first games at me and my brother
played together so it's just like it
brings back all these memories of us
actually playing together because he got
a Super Mario or he got a Super Nintendo
for Christmas and I own that's like
exactly what would happen it's like a
direct port where does the creepiness
come into it yeah it's like I have so
many memories of playing with my brother
on the Super Nintendo like way early
early childhood and it was just a fun
time for cooperative gameplay that's
where couch gaming like really started
but anyway this is supposed to be a
creep oh my god I can even look up like
I can in the game ah that's adorable I'm
dancing dancing chick amigo okay so oh
there we go oh wait what wait what wait
there we go
okay so what is that gonna do to me oh
oh god no what it wait a minute
Mario you don't look so happy over there
what happens if I go back down oh I
can't go back down I just got to go in
the oh god no hole well here we go
Mario start so why was Mario all worried
about this and what is this gonna do to
me hmm you are you are invincible now
somehow I don't think you know what
invincible means okay something Bad's
gonna happen oh man
where is this gonna go wrong also yes I
do have a brother his name is Tom he's
the author of the webcomic two kinds
some of you people mostly know about
that but some don't so yeah that's
pretty cool
he runs a webcomic he asked for like 11
or 12 years now pretty much the whole
time that I've known my brother
you know he's been drawings whoa whoa
was that a bleedy I bullet bill Oh
what's with the no face ghosts they
don't even need to hide their face
anymore they don't have face dan dad God
all this music is bringing back memories
I don't know whether be that to be
missed a leak or terrified I hate you
well yeah that was the name of the game
so is that coming from Luigi cuz Luigi
was Yakko hi hello big boos how you
doing oh man oh we're just gonna bloop
hey how's it going there how you doing
you doing good you look good okay god
I'm like I know this is supposed to be a
horror game but I'm really happy right
now because god I when I was well I was
watching recently they're not so
recently but I watched the game grumps
playthrough through Super Mario World
and like every topic that they touched
on was like a little piece of my child
and it was Lee ah so much nostalgia for
everything I loved - OH
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh wait what am I
supposed to go in that Piper am I
supposed to go beyond it coz there's
always a secret if you'll be on stuff
like Super Mario well do wha
hi Ouija how are you doing
no I can't swim up anymore oh I
shouldn't have gone over to the Ouija
side of things oh no I have to start
again
oh why won't you die I'm invincible
don't you know that oh did I actually
start over was that was that text there
before I don't remember because I was
paying attention I'd apologize everybody
I'm just having too much fun yeah God me
and my brother played so many
cooperative games like it was really
weird because couch gaming isn't as much
a thing as it is today and I really wish
it was because couch cooperative gaming
is one of the favorite things that I had
as a child and it's just like I wish I
could have it back okay oh man
Oh moving like sludge and why am i
underwater why do I have to be
underwater now I truly Emin I got a
thousand points why yours in I got ten
I'm rarely more than wet oh these flumps
had a fun time smashing a bunch of
strawberry jam but I'm not sure they're
gonna do much to me one of these guys is
gonna surprise me I'm gonna have a jammy
sweet surprise not like that get your
eye down together but why do I have to
repeatedly tell you guys to get your
minds out of gutter all the time it's
not like I put you there no way no how
and I'm gonna die on this I just know
I'm gonna get distracted derp out and
then smell whoa oh man I did wonder what
happened to all the extra Mario lives
that were lost during the course of
super mario world especially in star
road Oh
God if I can do a livestream where I
just played through Super Mario World I
would love that so much because it's
literally one of my favorite games it
was like when it came out in the SNES it
like blew everybody's minds and the game
grumps were saying that it wasn't as
successful as any other of the Super
Mario World
Super Mario games like Super Mario 3 was
unbelievably successful but I couldn't I
can't even fathom that this game isn't
success wasn't as successful I think it
still was but not as much whoa whoa oh
you son of a [ __ ]
ha ha ok I knew it's gonna be bad that
just goes to show kids don't eat
mushrooms when you're wandering around
in the Mushroom Kingdom
you want me to do it again too late yeah
it's like all the creepypasta images in
one okay I'm moving on sorry sorry
everybody
I'll just move on now ooh why am I
looking at the wall oh there's something
on the wall what is that I can't move
you thought Koopa worked alone Oh Luigi
oh no what what uh
oh god no what what happened Oh
Mario's crying what did he expect is
that really the Angus you son of a [ __ ]
goddamn you I guess I shouldn't expect
it any different let me load it back up
into the beginning of the game ah that's
so much better
this was actually a fun game it was
really weird how accurately represented
it was from the original I don't know if
he like ripped a ROM of the game from an
emulator and just decided to slap on his
own we'll finish there but God that was
so weird what the hell happened at the
end there I thought like Luigi was
actually gonna pull some creepy pasta
[ __ ] but just turned out that I killed
him
it's so horrible but either way that was
Mario dot exe hope you enjoyed it you
can check out Sonic and Sally dot exe in
the in the annotations over there in the
description below but you know like most
of these it's like they're based off of
creepypasta so you got to read the
creepypasta if you really want to know
about it I'm gonna try to find it
I think the creepypastas name is
actually I hate you so check that out in
the description below of it use me if
it's there thank you everybody so much
for watching click the MJ for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next
I don't remember a bunny care oh wait
picking up speed now Wow like that
actually grip the sonic engine out of
the old him